What we need is inheritance and that's a way to reuse classes to build new
classes. So what you wanted to do was to find these two new types, MainDish and
Appetizer, and both of these are types of Dishes. This means if we had a Dish
type, well, we could create the MainDish type by specializing the Dish type. And
we could create an Appetizer type by also specializing the Dish type. This is
called inheritance. We would say MainDish inherits from Dish. There's a lot of
terminology that goes along with this. We would say the MainDish inherits from
Dish and that's what these up arrows in our diagram means. If we look at it in
other direction, we would say MainDish and Appetizer are both subclasses of Dish
and we would say Dish is the base class, our superclass of MainDish and
Appetizer. There's a lot of different terminology people use to talk about this.
But the important thing to understand is that we're building the subclasses,
MainDish and A, which are special types of Dishes by starting from the Dish type
and adding some extra behavior to it. We can keep going. We could have a new
derived class based on theA class, and then the Pythonic Appetizer would inherit
from Appetizer. It would also inherit from Dish, and these subclass terms are
transitive, so Pythonic Appetizer is a subclass of Appetizer, it's also a
subclass of Dish. How does this look in code? Well, if you remember, when we
introduced the class syntax. We said there was this BaseClass as part of the
class definition. So far, we've used object for all of our BaseClasses. But the
BaseClass can be any other type. So, to get what we've shown here, we would have
the MainDish, have as its base class the Dish, and then the definition of the
MainDish class. And we would have the Appetizer, have as its base class, the
Dish and the Pythonic Appetizer has as its base class the Appetizer. What about
the Dish? Well, we didn't draw any BaseClass for that and its BaseClass is
object. That's the ultimate superclass of all classes we create in Python.